we have a whole bunch of economic news
we have GDP numbers we also have new
unemployment numbers unemployment
numbers probably will not talk about
today probably tomorrow but I do want to
talk about GDP so we are in the middle
of a pandemic we anticipated that q1 GDP
numbers q1 of course January February
March would not be great q2 in which we
are right now we expect to be really bad
and then there's certainly a question
mark around q3 and the idea that q4
numbers will be dramatically recovered
so what does the first quarter look like
why do we care about GDP well when we're
trying to figure out the economic impact
of the coronavirus we look at the stock
market even though it doesn't really
tell us that much and we've talked about
why before we look at unemployment how
many people are working how many people
are losing their jobs we look at wages
and we've also been waiting on GDP q1
GDP was down 4.8% this is the largest
drop since late 2008 in the throes of
the Great Recession this is the first
GDP decline at all in six years and it's
not surprising we were expecting this to
understand these numbers first it helps
to know what GDP is GDP is the gross
domestic product that's the total value
of goods produced and services provided
if you if you have two businesses a
factory and a hair salon for lack of a
better term for lack of a better example
the factory produces a hundred dollars
worth of goods the hair salon provides a
hundred dollars worth of haircuts that's
two hundred dollars in total product as
this GDP is measured of course there are
many other elements that go into it it
went down in the first quarter because
we had January and February which were
reasonably normal months as far as the
economy is concerned and then in March
stay at home order started because of
coronavirus businesses shut down fewer
things were sold fewer people were
working fewer services were provided in
the second quarter
which is April May June we are about a
third of the way through q2 there's the
idea that GDP could be down as much as
20% some people are even throwing around
the number 30% which is devastating
these are we've actually become numb
today we learned another 3.8 3.6
something like that million people filed
for unemployment last week that's way
down from a few weeks ago but it is an
insane number historically speaking and
we've become numb to these numbers of
absolute economic devastation so now
let's go beyond the headlines and really
dig into some of the data that made up
the GDP decline of 4.8% because that may
not be what you expected it's very
interesting so first of all we can
separate personal consumption into goods
and services as I mentioned before goods
and services combined to make up GDP
goods were actually almost unchanged
goods as part of q1 GDP we're only down
a tiny bit now maybe this is intuitive
maybe it's not durable goods like cars
and furnishings were certainly down P
there's not a lot of car sales going on
many dealerships are closed furnishings
people aren't really going out and
buying too much furniture right now but
non durable goods were actually up about
1% so that includes of course food and
beverages that are consumed off premises
meaning grocery stores that makes sense
Goods almost unchanged overall in total
services of course were down household
spending on services was down pretty
significantly about 6% but there was
also a major decrease in health care
spending and this is something that
really tells us a lot about how our
economy is organized and not
particularly for the better so you might
imagine wait a second we've got a
pandemic everything that's going on
right now is because of a medical
situation that people need treatment for
people are filling hospitals for how is
it that with a million almost 1.1
million confirmed cases of coronavirus
in the United States healthcare spending
was down during q1 and the answer is
that routine health care is almost
completely shut down every
thing from dermatology visits for a skin
rash to elective and non-emergency
surgery it's all but canceled it's all
but canceled this also reminds us that
the main point of our health care system
is to make money the economy is hugely
reliant on revenue from health care and
that's not good when in my view the main
goal of health care should be to keep
people and to make people healthy not to
make money this is a structural analysis
that can be done when you're trying to
think about how an industry functions if
we ask how do cable news channel what is
the main purpose of cable news channels
is it to inform people as much as
possible no it's to make money once you
understand the primary purpose of an
industry you understand why they make
the editorial decisions that they make
etc so on and so forth if you look at
the healthcare industry in the United
States when you realize well it's
primarily organized to be a profit
Center it's primarily organized to make
money it tells you a lot about why it
fails in the areas in which it fails and
what we are seeing during a medical
pandemic during a viral pandemic which
is a medical event we are seeing one of
the largest reductions in GDP came from
the healthcare industry because so much
of that industry of course you've got
emergency rooms which are very full you
have I see use you have hospital beds
but when you're looking at everything
from you know orthopedic you need to
have your knee scoped arthroscopic
surgery on your knee for example you're
putting that off orthopedic surgeries
are very very profitable you get the
idea so when we look at those numbers a
large portion of the decline in GDP and
q1 came from within the healthcare
industry so 4.8 percent decline in q1 if
we have a full quarter of lock down
April May June the numbers could be
absolutely devastating now some states
are starting to open probably too soon
remember though Trump can't open the
country Trump can't open states
governors can't even really do it they
can allow it
but even if business
start having employees standing there
waiting for you to come in if people
don't go in the numbers are not going to
be dramatically better my sense right
now is May is going to be not good but
it will probably be better than April
hopefully June can be salvaged to some
degree and I mean that both economically
psychologically socially culturally
everything but we just don't know we
have to go where the data takes us and
right now we are still having huge death
numbers which I think yesterday we found
another 24,000 new cases so we've been
in a plateau that's lasted about a full
months and I don't believe at the at the
national level we are clearly on the
other side of it states like New York
are nationally the numbers are still
very very high what if you could read 10
books in just one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinka stand what they do is
take thousands of popular nonfiction
books they condense them down into text
or audio that you can consume in 15
minutes blinka snakes sure that you're
getting all of the important core
insights from each book so it's perfect
for exploring a book you otherwise
wouldn't have time for there's a full
book you're thinking about buying you
can use blankets to get a sample first
just think how much you can enrich
yourself by being able to soak up an
entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes
I recently checked out the book podcast
marketing strategy by Daniel rolls and
Ciaran Rogers and so useful so
particularly applicable to what I'm
doing really recommended blink East has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about 8 bucks a month and you get the
entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video